let's dive into the 20 most anticipated
movies of 2024 from Superhero sequels to
musical adaptations and sci-fi
Adventures there's something for
everyone in this list so buckle up and
get ready as we kick off our list with
El muerto a movie based on one of
Spider-Man's most obscure allies the
film star's pop star turned actor Bad
Bunny as Juan Carlos Estrada Sanchez a
Mexican wrestler who is resurrected by
the Aztec god of death to fight evil the
film will be directed by Jonas quaron
the son of Alfonso quaron who co-wrote
gravity and directed desiardo El muerto
was originally set to hit theaters on
January 12th but may be experiencing
some setbacks next up is the Fall Guy a
film adaptation of an 80s TV show about
a stunt man who moonlights as a bounty
hunter the film stars Ryan Gosling and
Emily Blunt as the lead Duo and is
directed by David Leach who previously
helmed John Wick Atomic blonde Deadpool
2 and Hobbes and Shaw with that kind of
pedigree you can expect some awesome
action scenes and witty banter in this
movie The Fall Guy is scheduled for
release on March 1st Pixar is known for
making some of the most heartwarming and
imaginative animated films ever and
their next feature is no exception Elio
tells the story of an 11 year old boy
who is accidentally beamed up into space
and mistaken for an ambassador for Earth
on another planet the film is the
directorial debut of Adrian Molina who
previously worked on Coco Toy Story 4
and Luca Elio promises to be a fun and
touching Adventure that will appeal to
kids and adults alike the film is set to
land in theaters on March 1st Sony's
Spider-Man universe without Spider-Man
has had its ups and downs but Madame web
might be worth checking out the film
stars Dakota Johnson as Cassandra Webb a
clairvoyant woman who guides Spider-Man
and other heroes in the comics the film
also features Sydney Sweeney Adam Scott
and zosia Mame and supporting roles
Madame web is directed by SJ Clarkson
who has worked on TV shows like Jessica
Jones The Defenders and succession the
film will spin its web into theaters on
February 16th the Despicable Me
franchise is one of the most successful
and popular animated series ever
spawning three movies a spin-off in
minions and a sequel and minions the
rise of Gru Despicable Me 4 will be the
fourth installment in the main series
following The Adventures of Gru his wife
Lucy their adopted daughters Margot
Edith and Agnes and their lovable yellow
minions the film will feature the voices
of Steve Carell as Gru Kristen Wiig as
Lucy Miranda Cosgrove as Margot Dana
Guyer as Edith and Nev Cheryl as Agnes
the film is directed by Kyle balda and
Brad Abelson who also directed minions
the rise of Gru Despicable Me 4 will hit
theaters on July 3rd Amy Winehouse was
one of the most talented and troubled
singers of our time and her life story
certainly deserves a proper biopic Back
to Black is that biopic starring Marissa
Abella as the iconic vocalist Who Rose
to fame with her Soulful voice and
grammy-winning albums but struggled with
addiction and personal demons until her
tragic death in 2011. the film is
directed by Sam Taylor Johnson who
previously hummed Nowhere Boy and 50
Shades of Gray Back to Black will hit
the screens in early 2024. Disney's
live-action remake of The Lion King was
a huge hit in 2019 but many fans felt
that it lacked the charm and emotion of
the original animated classic well
Disney is hoping to redeem themselves
with Mufasa The Lion King a prequel that
explores the backstory of Simba's father
and his rise to power and the pride
lands the film features Aaron Pierre as
Mufasa Seth Rogen as Pumbaa Billy Eisner
as Timon Kelvin Harrison ascar and John
Connie as Rafiki the film is directed by
Barry Jenkins who won an Oscar for
moonlight and also directed if Beale
Street could talk Mufasa The Lion King
will Roar into theaters on July 5th Poe
is back for the fourth installment of
the Kung Fu Panda franchise and he's
ready to kick some butt the film will
continue the adventures of The Lovable
Panda and his friends the furious five
as they face new threats and challenges
in their quest to master the art of kung
fu the film features the voices of Jack
Black as Poe Angelina jolia's Tigress
Dustin Hoffman as Shifu Seth Rogen as
mantis Lucy Lewis Viper David Cross as
Crane and James Hong as Mr ping the film
is directed by Jennifer U Nelson who
also directed Kung Fu Panda 2 and 3.
this film is set to chop its way into
theaters on March 8th one of the most
beloved musicals of all time is wicked
based on Gregory McGuire's novel that
reimagines the story of The Wizard of
from the perspective of Elphaba aka the
Wicked Witch of the West the musical has
been a smash hit on Broadway and around
the world since 2003 and fans have been
eagerly awaiting for a movie adaptation
for years well the wait is almost over
because Wicked part 1 is coming to
theaters in 2024. the film stars Ariana
Grande as Glinda Cynthia ervio as
Elphaba Jeff Goldblum as the wizard
Michelle yo as Madame morable Jonathan
Bailey as Fierro and Adina Menzel the
original Elphaba as Nessa Rose the film
is directed by John M Chu who previously
hummed crazy Rich Asians and in the
Heights Wicked part 1 will defy gravity
on November 27th the Lord of the Rings
is one of the most beloved and acclaimed
fantasy franchises ever and it's getting
a new addition in 2024 the Lord of the
Rings The War of the rohiram is an
animated prequel that will explore the
history of Helm's Deep The Fortress that
was the site of an epic battle in The
Two Towers the film will focus on Helm
hammerhand the legendary King of Rohan
who fought against the dunlandings and
their sorcerer leader frika the film
will feature the voice of Richard
armitage's Helm coming back after The
Hobbit trilogy the film is directed by
Kenji kamayama who previously worked on
anime series like Ghost in the Shell
Standalone complex and Eden of the East
this film is set to charge into theaters
on April 12th John Wick is definitely
one of the coolest and deadliest
assassins ever but he's not the only one
in his world ballerina is a spin-off
that will focus on a female assassin who
seeks revenge against the people who
killed her family it's the first
spin-off of the John Wick franchise and
is set between the events of John Wick
chapter 3 Parabellum and John Wick
chapter 4. it stars Anna De armas
Angelica Huston Gabriel Byrne Lance
Reddick Catalina sandino Moreno Norman
Reedus Ian McShane and Keanu Reeves the
film is directed by Len Weissman who
previously hummed underworld and live
Freer Die Hard ballerina will hit
theaters on June 7th Pixar is back with
Inside Out 2 a sequel that will explore
the teenage mind of Riley who's now 16
years old and facing new challenges and
emotions the film will feature Amy
Poehler as Joy Phyllis Smith as sadness
Bill Hader as fear Lewis Black as anger
Mindy Kaling as discussed and Caitlyn
Diaz as Riley the film is directed by
Kelsey mon who previously worked on
onward and Monsters University Inside
Out 2 is set to hit theaters on June
14th a quiet place was one of the most
terrifying and original horror movies of
2018 in its sequel a quiet place part 2
was equally thrilling and suspenseful in
2021 but a quiet place day one is a
prequel that will show you how the world
became overrun by deadly creatures that
hunt by sound the film stars Lupita
Nyong'o as a woman who fights for her
survival during an alien invasion in New
York City the film also features Joseph
Quinn as her brother Alex Wolf as her
boyfriend and Killian Murphy as a
mysterious stranger who helps them along
the way the film is directed by Michael
sarnosky who previously helmed pigs
starring Nicholas Cage a quiet place day
one will make you scream on March 8th
the Marvel Cinematic Universe is always
expanding and evolving in one of its
newest additions is Captain America
Brave New World the film will follow Sam
Wilson aka the Falcon who took up the
mantle of Captain America at the end of
Avengers endgame and continued his
journey in the Falcon in the Winter
Soldier TV series the film will feature
Anthony Mackey as Sam Wilson Sebastian
Stan as Bucky Barnes Emily VanCamp as
Sharon Carter Wyatt Russell as John
Walker and Julia Louis-Dreyfus as
Valentina Allegra de Fontaine the film
is directed by Carrie skogland who also
directed all six episodes of the Falcon
and the Winter Soldier Captain America
Brave New World will fly into theaters
on July 26th Gladiator was one of the
most epic and acclaimed movies of 2000
winning five Oscars including best
picture and best actor for Russell Crowe
Gladiator 2 will be the long-awaited
sequel that will continue the story of
Maximus Decimus Meredith the Roman
general who became a gladiator and
Avenged his family and Emperor the film
will feature an amazing cast including
Denzel Washington Pedro Pascal Joseph
Quinn and Connie Nielsen the film is
directed by Ridley Scott who also
directed the first Gladiator and other
Classics like alien Blade Runner and
Thelma and Louise Gladiator 2 will enter
the arena on November 22nd Mission
Impossible dead reckoning part 2 is the
eighth and final installment in the
Mission Impossible film series following
Mission Impossible dead reckoning part
1. the film will feature Tom Cruise's
Ethan Hunt finishing out the story left
on a cliffhanger from the previous movie
the film is directed by Christopher
McQuarrie who also directed the previous
three films in the series Mission
Impossible dead reckoning part 2 will
explode into theaters on June 28th the
Thunderbolts is an upcoming superhero
film based on the Marvel Comics team of
the same name featuring a group of
reformed villains who work for the
government the film will feature
Sebastian Stan as Bucky Barnes Florence
Pugh as Jelena biloba David Harbor as
the Red Guardian Wyatt Russell as U.S
agent Olga kurylinko as Taskmaster
Hannah John Caiman as ghost Julia
Louis-Dreyfus as Valentina Allegra de
Fontaine and Harrison Ford as thadius
Ross or the Red Hulk the film is
directed by Jake schreier and will storm
into theaters on December 20th one of
the most surprising and successful
movies of 2019 was Joker starring
Joaquin Phoenix as the iconic Batman
villain in a gritty origin story that
earned him an Oscar for best actor well
Phoenix is back for Joker foliado a
sequel that will explore his
relationship with Harley Quinn played by
Lady Gaga in her first comic book role
the film is directed by Todd Phillips
who also helmed the first Joker and the
hangover Trilogy Joker felia do will
laugh its way into theaters on October
4th Ryan Reynolds Deadpool is one of the
most popular and hilarious superheroes
ever and he's finally joining the Marvel
Cinematic Universe in Deadpool 3. the
film Will Follow The Merc with a mouth
as he interacts with other MCU
characters and breaks the fourth wall
like never before the film will also
feature Hugh Jackman as the iconic
character Wolverine Deadpool 3 is
directed by David Leach who also
directed Deadpool 2 and John Wick this
film will slice and dice its way into
theaters on May 4th Spider-Man beyond
the spider-verse is the third and final
chapter in the spider-verse trilogy
following Spider-Man into the
spider-verse and Spider-Man across the
spider-verse the film will feature
shamique Moore as Miles Morales Haley
Steinfeld as Gwen Stacy Oscar Isaac as
Miguel O'Hara and mahershala Ali as
Aaron Davis the film is directed by
Joaquin dos Santos Kemp powers and
Justin K Thompson Spider-Man beyond the
spider-verse will swing into theater in
late 2024. one thing to keep in mind
with these release dates is that a lot
of them are flexible especially with the
ongoing strikes in Hollywood let me know
in the comments what movies you're
looking forward to most don't forget to
subscribe for more of my content and if
you liked the video check out the one on
your screen too